>> I AM GOING TO ASSUME
EVERYBODY IN THAT VIDEO IS
THERE OF THEIR OWN FREE WILL,
DESPITE BEING
SARAN WRAPPED TO A LADDER.
WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA, WHOA.
THAT'S HOW YOU CATCH
A DISEASE, SHOOTING THOSE VIRUS
MOLECULES UP YOUR POOP CHUTE.
WHAT NUMBER SHADE OF GREY IS
THAT?
THIS IS WHAT WOMEN WANT NOW,
FELLAS.
BOX OFFICE RECEIPTS DON'T LIE.
I'M NOT SURPRISED.
I'VE HAD AN S&M FRIENDLY
WORK PLACE FOR YEARS.
WE DO FETISH ON THE FIVES.
>> FETISH ON THE FIVES.
>> NO JUDGMENT, JUST ROUGH
EXPLORATION OF OUR BODIES
AT FIVE MINUTES AFTER
EVERY HOUR.
>> IT'S 2:05 GUYS.
PUT ON YOUR BLINDFOLDS.
>> I SEE MY WRITERS
ARE READY FOR SOME PLEASURE.
>> [SCREAMS]
>> PLAY WITH YOUR KEYBOARD.
PRESS THE KEYS HARDER.
>> AH.
>> GRONKOWSKI.
GRONKOWSKI.
>> OH!
IS IT 3:05 ALREADY?
>> FLY TRUE, MY FRIEND.
>> OW!
>> I HOPE YOU'RE READY FOR
$9,000 WORTH OF YANKEE.
[ALL SCREAM]
>> THE SARAN WRAP IS FUSING
TO MY SKIN.
>> GRONKOWSKI.
>> JUST ONE OF THE MANY PERKS OF
NOT HAVING AN HR DEPARTMENT.
WHOO, HOT!
WAS THAT JARED LETO?